اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذا الموجز الاخباري
الذي نبداه بهذه الصور التي وصلتنا منذ
قليل لزياره مفاجئه قام بها رئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن الى اوكرانيا وتحديدا الى
العاصمه كياف التي هي الاولى منذ اندلاع
الحرب الروسيه طبعا نشاهد الرئيس يعني
يدخل الى ما يعني يسمى بالجدار التذكاري
لقتل الحرب في ساحه القديس ميخائيل فيكياف
وسط اجراءات امنيه مشدده
طبعا كان هناك تكتم اوكراني كبير والغاء
للعديد من
اللقاءات التي كانت مقرره بسبب هذه
الزياره
وكان نائب وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه تحدث
عن زياره لشركاء
مهمين بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
وحديث عن تقديم المزيد من المساعدات اذا
نشاهد بهذه الصور
زيلينسكي يرافق بايدن في جوله على شوارع
العاصمه الاوكرانيه
طبعا كان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن من
المفترض ان يتواجد في بولندا هذا الاسبوع
لمناقشه تقديم المزيد من الدعم الدعم
العسكري
لحلفاء اوكرانيا في مواجهه
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه على اوكرانيا
في ظل ضغوط
من اجل تزويد اكياف بالطائرات اف 16 كانت
طلبتها
باخر التصريحات كياف
وقالت بانه يمكن ان تساهم في قلبي موازين
الحرب
طبعا
مسؤولون الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني يجتمعون
اليوم
الاثنين
بالذكرى الاولى لهذه الحرب او العمليه
العسكريه كما تسميها روسيا مره عام على
هذه العمليه العسكريه اذا
باهم نقاط اجنده البحث هي مناقشه النقص في
الذخيره لدى اوكرانيا
وامكانيه شرائها وتامينها لها
اذا جوله لبيضن
تحديدا الى الحائط التذكري لقتل الجيش
الاوكراني
في هذه الحرب
الدائره منذ عام
طبعا يرافق بايدن
الرئيس الاوكراني
ليست بقريبه
حتى انه لم يتم اعلام وسائل الاعلام
بموعد او توقيت او حتى هذه الزياره
طبعا منذ عام اندلعت هذه الحرب وفرضت
بعضها
العديد من الدول الاوروبيه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه عقوبات
اقتصاديه وصفت بلقاسيه على روسيا
في محاوله لعزل الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين
بالمقابل طبعا
روسيا ردت بقطع الغاز عن الدول الاوروبيه
التي لازلت تعاني الان بتامين امدادات
يعني بديله
لها
وينضم الينا للتعليق على زياره الرئيس جو
بايدن الى كييف الصحفي محمد البابا تحديدا
من كييف ماذا تعني سيد محمد هذه الزياره
المفاجئه لكياف بعد عام على هذه العمليه
العسكريه
نعم يعني سياره غير متوقعه ومفاجئه للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه
وتتزامن مع حدثين او موعدين رئيسيا اليوم
العشرين من شباط هو يوم انتصار ثوره
الميدان وذكرى هروب الرئيس الموالي لروسيا
نعم
يبدو ان الاتصال انقطع مع الصحفي محمد
البابا من كافكان مراسلنا في كاف تحدث عن
يعني زحمه سير غير مبرره لم يعرف سببها في
العاصمه كياف ولكن السبب يعني يعني اصبح
واضحا هو زياره للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
عاد الاتصال مع الصحه في محمد البابا يمكن
ان تكمل حديثك محمد يعني كنت تتحدث عن
اهميه هذه الزياره في هذا التوقيت
اذا نعود ونشاهد الصور الاولى
وصور اقرب لهذه الزياره
لجو بايدن
الى شوارع العاصمه كياف
في خطوه
في خطوه طبعا داعمه لكياف
نشاهد زيلينسكي
ويعني هناك
حراسه امنيه ومرافقه لعسكريين
محمد يعني نشاهد هذه الصور
ويمكنك معنى التعليق عليها لهذه الزياره
تاتي في ذكرى انتصار ثوره الميدان في
العشرين من فبراير وايضا تاتي قبل اربعه
ايام من الذكرى السنويه الاولى لبدء الغزو
الروسي للاراضي الاوكرانيه وايضا يعني
الدور الامريكي الكبير الذي لعبته
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في دعم
اوكرانيا اقتصاديا وعسكريا وخاصه يعني
خلال الفتره الماضيه التي شهدت اخذ ورد من
بعض الدول الاوروبيه ولعبت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه دور كبير في اقناع
الشركاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي حلف
الناتو لتزويد اوكرانيا ودعم اوكرانيا
بالعتاد والسلاح ولا ننسى انه ما يجري في
شرق اوكرانيا الان من هجوم كبير لروسيا
وللقوات الروسيه على المناطق او على يعني
وحدات الجيش الاوكراني خاصه محاوله تطويق
والدخول الى مدينه باكمول يعني رساله يعني
رساله كبيره رساله دعم كبيره لاوكرانيا
وللشعب الاوكراني وللرنسكي وايضا يعني كان
هناك
امر لافت انه اثناء وجود الرئيس جو بايدن
داخل يعني كنيسه صفير التي تعتبر من اقدم
الكنائس في اوكرانيا دورت سفارات الانذار
في معظم الاراضي الاوكرانيه واثناء يعني
كانت يسمع اثناء الخروج الرئيس برفقه
الرئيسكي من الكنيسه باتجاه يعني السيارات
بشكل كبير وهذا يعني اوردناك خبر عاجل على
العربيه كنا توقعنا ان هناك يعني ضربه على
العاصمه كاف وباقي المناطق ولكن ها هو
السبب السيد محمد يعني فعليا رسائل واضحه
لروسيا الى اي مدى يمكن ان تستفزه هذه
الزياره بهذا التوقيت
يعني نعم يعني بهذا التوقيت والتي والتي
كان من المنتظر ان تكون روسيا بهجوم كبير
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه ياتي
ليؤكد دعم والوقوف الى جانب الشعب
الاوكراني يعني روسيا في موقف لا تحسد
عليه خاصه ان يعني ما يجري في شرق
اوكرانيا ويعني خلال الساعات القليله
الماضيه كان هناك يعني تحرك كبير للجيش
الاوكراني وتراجعت القوات الروسيه خاصه في
منطقه كريمينيا التي تقع في مقاطعه ايضا
ولا ننسى يعني الدعم الامريكي المفتوح
والغير مسبوق لاوكرانيا هو يعني من
الاسباب الاساسيه والرئيسيه التي ادت الى
صمود اوكرانيا وتحقيقها انتصارات مثلا
انسحاب او تراجع القوات الروسيه وخساره
القوات الروسيه في خرسون التي اصبحت عادت
مدينه خرسون الى اوكرانيا بفعل وفي تاثير
لمنظومات هي التي كان لها دور كبير والتي
قدمتها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى
اوكرانيا
سيد محمد يعني هذه الزياره تاتي قبل يوم
من زياره بايدن المعلنه الى بولندا حيث
سيجتمع قاده اوروبيون لدعم وحشد المزيد من
المساعدات العسكريه لكياف ما الذي يمكن ان
يقدم بعد
يعني الان الحديث
يتعلق
بالتزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات غربيه منها
مقاتلات اف 16 خاصه ان هناك عدد من الدول
الاوروبيه يعني اعلن استعداده لتزويد
اوكرانيا بهذه المقاتلات بعد موافقه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وايضا هناك
عمليه تسريع تدريب القوات الاوكرانيه في
بولندا في المانيا في تشيكيا وايضا في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وقبل يومين
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه انها انها
تدريب 600 جندي اوكراني على استخدام بعض
انواع الدبابات يعني اليات برادلي
ومنظومات دفاعيه لذلك يعني هذا الاجتماع
سيكون اجتماع كبير وستكون هناك اعلان عن
مساعدات ضخمه للقوات الاوكرانيه ويتداول
ان بولندا فقط بولندا ستعلن انها ستتولى
تدريب يعني لواء كامل تدريب وتجهيز واعداد
لواء كامل من الجيش الاوكراني سيكون لواء
من المدرعات والدبابات سيد محمد يعني الى
متى سيستمر هذا الدعم يعني هذا هو السؤال
الذي يطرح مرارا وتكرارا في ظل يعني
استمرار هذه الحرب عام مضى ولا احد يعلم
كم ستستمر
التي اطلقها الرئيس بايدن والتي ستستمر
في نهايه هذا العام وسيكون هناك يعني
استمرار لتقليل الدعم العسكري والدعم
اللوجيسي الكبير للجيش الاوكراني وتدريب
الجنود الاوكرانيين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تلعب دور كبير في دعم اوكرانيا
بمدها بالاسلحه والعتاد وايضا بالدعم
المالي والاقتصادي لاوكرانيا لانه يتوازى
مع الدعم العسكري اوكرانيا بحاجه الى دعم
اقتصادي كبير في ظل انهيار يعني الاقتصاد
الاوكراني بفعل الغزو الروسي الاراضي
الاوكرانيه نعم يعني نذكر بالصور التي
نراها وما يعلنه بايدن تباعا من العاصمه
الاوكرانيه في هذه السياره المفاجئه بانه
بوتين كان مخطئا حينما بدا هجومه على
اوكرانيا
طبعا كان هناك تصريحات اليوم لوزير
الخارجيه وزير خارجيه امريكا انتوني بلينك
في مؤتمر صحفي مع نظيره التركي
ويعني تم التطرق الى الحرب الروسيه من عده
جوانب ولكن يعني هذه
التهديدات اذا صح التعبير باي اطار تضعها
يعني هناك مناقشات طويله الان يقول بايدن
مطوله معزلنسكي حول دعم اوكرانيا سؤال
يذهب الى ضيفنا
السيد ايهاب عباس السياسي من واشنطن اهلا
بك سيد عباس يعني يعني قراءتك الاولى لهذه
الزياره
اهلا بحضرتك واهلا بكل المشاهدين طبعا هي
زياره مفاجئه لاوكرانيا وتاتي تحديدا
تقريبا في يوم ذكرى بدايه هذه الحرب يعني
اليوم نحن 20 فبراير كمان اربعه ايام
ستكون هذه هي الذكرى الاولى اعتقد هي
زياره لتوضيح ان الولايات المتحده ما زالت
تقف بجانب اوكرانيا بشكل كبير وقوي في وقت
مهم يعني هناك اخبار في داخل الامريكي
تتحدث عن ان الدعم الامريكي لاوكرانيا
ربما سيقل خلال الفتره القادمه بسبب سيطره
الجمهوريين على المشهد في مجلس النواب
الامريكي وايضا الاخبار التي ترددت حول
ربما قله المخزون الامريكي من الاسلحه
والذخائر التي تقدم لاوكرانيا
سيجعل سيجعلان هذان الامران
وضع المساعدات الامريكيه لاوكر ربما في
مهب الرياح ولكن هذه الزياره اعتقد انها
زياره كبيره وتاتي من بوابه الامل
الامريكيه التي تراها اداره جو بايدن في
استمرار الدعم الامريكي اللامحدود
لاوكرانيا في وقت بالمناسبه كانت لدينا
هنا بالامس في واشنطن مظاهره شارك فيها ما
يخرج من الفي شخص تقريبا من بينهم سياسيون
وفنانون امريكيون ايضا
للتنديد بالدعم المفرط التي تقدمه اداره
بايدن
للاوكرانيين هل يمكن لهذه الضغوط اللي
كانت ممارسه من قبل الجمهوريين بعد
سيطرتهم على مجلس النواب الامريكي او من
هذه الوجوه السياسيه او حتى
الفاعله في المجتمع الامريكي ان تؤثر على
الدعم بالمقابل على الارض المزيد من الدعم
يعني بايدن الان سنعلن عن عقوبات اضافيه
ضد النخب والش ركات الروسيه وسنزيد الدعم
العسكري لاوكرانيا
يعني من الممكن طبعا هناك فيما يبدو في
الولايات المتحده سيكون لدينا خلال فتره
القادمه صراع سياسي علني
اختلاف وخلافات كبيره فيما يتعلق بمساله
اوكرانيا في مقابل دعم المواطن الامريكي
لان اليوم لدينا المواطنون الامريكيون
اصبحوا يرزحون تحت وطاه العقوبات
الامريكيه والاوروبيه التي فرضت على روسيا
والتي اتت بما يسمى بالباك فاير او بتاثير
السلبي العكسي على المواطن الامريكي وجيبه
واصبح المواطن الامريكي اليوم مثله مثل
المواطن الروسي الذي يعاني من العقوبات
التي هي مفروضه على بلاده بسبب هذه الحرب
وما حدث من تضخم خلال الفتره الماضيه
ومحاولات الفيدرالي الامريكي التغلب عليها
برفع اسعار الفائده كلها فتره قصيره
ادى الى ان يكون هناك حاله تململ لدى
المواطن الامريكي
وعدم تاكد من وضع المستقبل سواء له او
لابنائه
لوظيفته ولتامينه الصحي
لمدخراته كل هذه الامور تؤثر بالسلب على
مزاج المواطن الامريكي لذلك نشاهد
السوشيال ميديا او وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي اصبح التعاوز ايضا بالاعتراض من
المواطنين الامريكيين الذين ايضا بداوا
يعني
يتنذرون ويلقون النكات المختلفه على اداره
جو بايدن لهذا الملف
وبداوا يطالبون بشكل واضح على المساعدات
التي تقدم لاوكرانيا وتقديمها للداخل
الامريكي
والاهتمام
بمحاوله ايجاد حل سلمى ودبلوماسي لهذا
الصراع بين اوكرانيا وروسيا لكن حتى الان
لا توجد اي دلائل ان اداره بايدن ستذهب في
هذا الاتجاه سيد ايهاب ابقى معي نشاهد
لازلنا هذه الصور التي وصلتنا منذ قليل
لزياره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى كياف
طبعا هي زياره مفاجئه قبل التوجهه الى
بولندا للقاء قاده الجبهه الشرقيه
في الذكرى الاولى لاندلاع الحرب في
اوكرانيا طبعا وسائل اعلام اوكرانيه كانت
ذكرت تعقيبا على هذه الزياره بانه رئيس
بايدن التقى
وكان هناك اجتماع
بكاتدرائيه القديس ميخائيل في اكياب ثم
نشاهد هذه الصور لزياره بايدن للجدار
التذكاري لقتل الحرب في صحه القديس
ميخائيل وكنا تحدثنا عن اطلاق صافرات
الانذار في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كاف
وغالبيه مناطق
البلاد
سيد ايهاب يعني تحدثنا عن نقطه مهمه جدا
عن قله المخزون لدى الجانب الامريكي قله
المخزون لا يعاني منها فقط الجانب
الامريكي منذ اسبوع تقريبا كان النيتو
يعني اعلن عن مخاوفه من نقص ذخيراته في
حال حصل اشتباك مباشر مع روسيا
صحيح بكل تاكيد طبعا قله المخزون الامريكي
بدات تظهر للعيان قبل حوالي ثلاثه اشهر
تقريبا عندما
دعت واشنطن كوريا الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
لاعاده يعني تقوم باعاده شراء اسلحه كانت
قد باعتها في صفقه كبيره لكوريا الجنوبيه
حتى تقوم بتوجيهها من كوريا الجنوبيه الى
اوكرانيا مره اخرى
وكانت هذه هي بدايه
يعني شعور المواطن الامريكي بان هناك
مشكله ما فيما يتعلق بمخزون الاسلحه
الامريكي بالاضافه الى انه واشنطن قامت في
ذلك التوقيت ايضا تقريبا او بعدها ربما
باسبوعين او ثلاثه
بالاتفاق على صفقه قنابل صغيره توضع على
محركات صواريخ صغيره
كبدائل لصواريخ ذات قدرات اعلى وكان هذا
امر غريب ايضا فيبدو ان هناك مشكله فيما
يتعلق بالمخزون
الامريكي وايضا نذكر بان الجنرال مارك
ميري رئيس اركان الامريكيه المشتركه كان
قد قال ابان فتره الانتخابات الانتخابات
التجديده النصفي الماضيه انه انا الاوان
لاداره جو بايدن ان تسعى لوقف هذه الحرب
بالاشكال الدبلوماسيه المختلفه وكرر هذه
الدعوه مره اخرى بعد ذلك بحوالي شهرين اي
ربما تقريبا الشهر الماضي قبل ربما اربعه
اسابيع على اقصى تقدير
سنتابع معك هذه التغطيه لزياره بايدن التي
يصفها بانها دليل قوي جدا على دعم
الاوكرانيين وينضم الينا منك مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل حذيفه
تتحدث عن تجدد ذوي صفارات الانذار في كاف
بالتزامن مع زياره بايدن
تحياتي هذا صحيح طبعا انطلقت صافرات
الاندار العاصمه
في وقت تجول الرئيس الاوكراني والرئيس
في اتحاد تكييف تحديدا في الصحف القديسه
الصوفيه
وكنيسه القديس لهذا هذه الجوله عمي بها
زياره حائط الحائط التذكاري للمئه
السماويه ونسميها الاوكرانيون وهي طبعا
ذكرى اليوم هي الذكرى السنويه لمقتل 100
مواطن اوكراني كما يقول الاوكرانيون على
يد قنصه هم يصفون الوضع بان الحكومه التي
كانت في ذلك في العام 2014 عندما اندلعت
الثوره
على الحكومه المواليه القناص وهم كانوا
قناصه الروس كانوا يرفضون حركه المقاومه
عن اوكرانيه للحكومه المواليه للاتحاد
الروسي وان الشخص
كان
اليوم هي الذكرى السنويه وتاتي زياره الى
الذكرى السنويه لاحياء الذكرى السنويه
للمئه السماويه وهم المواطنين الذين قتلوا
وهم الان صورهم معلقه
على
العاصمه
اسمح لي
اسمح لي لنشاهد هذه الصور او هذه الصوره
فعليا للقاء الرسمي الذي جمع
بايدن الرئيس الامريكي مع الرئيس
الاوكراني
اذا هذه هي صوره اللقاء
كنت اتحدث فعليا هذا اللقاء نذكر بانه حصل
في كاتدرائيه القديس ميخائيل في العاصمه
كياف ونيويورك تايمز بايدن وصل الى كييف
عبر قطار صباح اليوم اذا وصل بايدن الى
كياف عبر قطار حذيفه كنت اتحدث عن مظاهر
العاصمه كيا في اطار هذه الزياره
والمزيد من الصور التي نشاهدها
للسيده الاولى ايضا سيده اوكرانيا الاولى
الى جانب بايدن
تفضل حذيفه
يبدو ان حذيفه لا يسمعني سيد عباس سيد
ايهاب عباس انت معي
نعم تفضل كنا نتحدث عن قله المخزون ان كان
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه من
الاسلحه وايضا بالنسبه كيف يمكن مواجهته
في اطار هذه الضغوط الكبيره التي ليس فقط
حكومه بايت ان تتعرض لها انما ايضا
الحكومات الاوروبيه الضغوطات الاقتصاديه
والضغوطات الشعبيه والمظاهرات التي تحصل
بين الحين والاخر لايقاف هذا الدعم بظلم
ما يدفعه المواطن الاوروبي من ضريبه
طبعا ستكون الحكومات الاوروبيه وحكومه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه امام ضغوط
كبيره في هذا الاطار خاصه واننا ايضا قبل
الحرب الروسيه كنا
خرجنا للتو او في اواخر الخروج من ازمه
كورونا وما اثرت عليه فيما يتعلق بسلاسل
الامداد في كافه المجالات ومن بينها
مجالات التكنولوجيا المتعلقه طبعا
بالقطاعات العسكريه المختلفه وهذا ما يقلل
حجم الانتاج من الاسلحه والذخائر والمعدات
خاصه المعدات الثقيله التي تستخدم ما يسمى
بالكمبيوتر شيبس او الرقاق الالكترونيه
التي تدخل في الصناعات العسكريه المختلفه
ونعلم انها كانت كان هناك وما زال حتى
الان يعني شحف في امدادات هذه
الوسائل التكنولوجيه الحديثه وهنا الحديثه
وهناك ايضا صراع حولها مع الصين
ومصانع كثيره اغلقت في تايوان تتعلق بهذه
الصناعات
يعني تشكل هذه المشكله
عائقا كبيرا امام الانتاج بكثره وبوفره
والمخزون الامريكي بدات التحدث عنه
العسكري طبعا لا تتحدث عنه علنا بانه اصبح
يعاني وان امريكا اليوم لن تكون جاهزه اذا
اضطرت بشكل مفاجئ ان تدخل مثلا في حرب
عسكريه مع الصين ستتاثر بشكل سلبي كبير
جدا
بالمناسبه لجان الدفاع ولجان الجيش داخل
المجلس النواب الامريكي التي اصبحت تسيطر
عليها الرؤيه الجمهوريه طبعا اليوم بشكل
كبير تعلم هذا الامر وتخشى ان تتعرض
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لازمه
لها علاقه بالاسلحه ستكون محرجه ومفاجئه
طبعا الامريكيين اذا مضطروا لفتح جبهه
جديده
للقتال برغم ان امريكا اليوم ليست في حرب
مع روسيا الى انها استهلكت كميه كبيره من
الذخائر باسرها الى اوكرانيا ما يدعو
المواطن الامريكي يقول لكي يقول ان امريكا
بالفعل هي في حرب غير معلنه مع روسيا
بالوكاله تقوم بها اوكرانيا
المتحدثه سيد ايهاب باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه زخرفه بانه الهدف من وراء هذه
الحرب هي يعني تغيير النظام
بروسيا وحسب الصور التي نراها وتقول
الوكالات بانها مباشره لهذا اللقاء الذي
يجمع الرئيس بايدن وايضا
في هذه الصوره بوجود مسؤولين من الجانبين
طبعا
تؤكد بانه اداره بايد النفط زيارته لكياف
اكثر من مره وانه البيت الابيض اخفى هذه
الرحله عن جدوله وغادر واشنطن بدون سابق
انذار
وكانت اثبات حدثت عن انه بايدن وصل
عبر القطار واستغرقت ساعته رحلته ساعه
واحده
ايهاب يعني ونحن نشاهد هذه الصور
اللقاء والسلام بايدن ولقاء لوزراء بحكومه
زينسكي
يعني اود ان اسالك عن ما سيكون رد بوتين
الجانب الروسي على هذه الزياره هل تتوقع
مزيدا من التصعيد العسكري خاصه في ظل
اشتعال جبهات دنياتك وبخموت
[موسيقى]
رئيس الولايات المتحده الذي يزور كييف في
وقت يعني من المفترض ان تهدا فيه العمليات
العسكريه المتعلقه على اقل تقدير بالعاصمه
وضواحيها لكن ان يتم اطلاق سفارات الانذار
فهذا ايضا ربما يعد سيعد استفزاز من
الجانب الروسي للجانب الامريكي لكن
الولايات المتحده ستضبط النفس في نهايه
المطاف ولن يكون هناك اي تحركات بشكل
مباشر عسكري مع الجانب الروسي برغم من ان
كل المفاجات وارده يعني من الممكن
يعني ض
مه اليه هل هناك من تحديثات حذيفه ونحن
نشاهد هذه الصور للقاء بين بايدن
ابدا بالمظاهر التي سبقت هذه الزياره في
الحقيقه العاصمه في مركز المدينه وهنا
اتحدث عن نطاق واسع جدا وكبير جدا حتى ان
الامر كان مستغرب جدا بالنسبه للجميع امر
نادر الحدوث ان يتم اغلاق واس
ع المنطقه الرئاسيه وليس فقط في مركز
المدينه القيادي وانما عيد جدا تم ضرب طوق
امني كبير وتم اغلاق الطرق ومنع المواطنين
من العبور عن هذه من هذه الطرق وهذا سبب
طبعا عن حركه جيعان في العاصمه كبيره جدا
حتى ان بعضها الجسور التي تربط الضفه
اليسرى الضفه اليمنى اصبح الدستور مشاهده
جسور التي تنقل المواطنين الى مركز
المدينه والى اعمالهم هذا منذ الليله
الماضيه تمت عمليه الاغلاق وحتى الان
العاصمه كيف تعاني من زحام كبير جدا هذا
هذه المظاهره التي سبقت وتصاحب الان هذه
الديانه طبعا تعلمين ان الرئيس غرد وقال
ان زيارتك
هذا
مع صوره تجمعه بالرئيس الامريكي طبعا
اول من خلال من خلال
الصفحات الرسميه رئيس الامريكي وقال مع
اقتران الثانويه
طبعا بالغزو الروسي الوحشي لاوكرانيا قال
واعاده تاكيد التزامنا الراسخ ديمقراطيه
اوكرانيا وسيادتها وسلامه لهذه رساله بايد
الى هذه الزياره لبايدن بهذا التوقيت
يبدو ان السيد ليس جاهزا سؤالي لك سيد
عباس يعني بالفتره الاخيره كان هناك تاكيد
من الجانب الاوكراني على
استعاده والنيه لاستعاده مناطق القرن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه رغم انها
تدعم بشكل كبير
اكياف عسكريا لكنها لا تحبذ هذه المعركه
لعده اسباب
برايك كيف ستتطور الامور بهذه المناطق هل
يمكن ربما ان تحسب حسابا للراي الامريكي
نعم فيما طلب هذا السؤال هناك تصريحات
لمسولين الملكين بالامس فهم منها انها
دعوه لاوكرانيا كي تقوم بالاستعداد لشن
هجمات داخل جزيره القرم وهذا يعد تغيرا في
الموقف الامريكي الذي لا يدعو لاثاره
مساله القرن في هذا التوقيت
وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالجوانب العسكريه
وبالتالي هذا يعد ايضا تصعيدا في مقابل من
الولايات المتحده يعني كنا نعتقد ان اداره
جو بايدن لا تريد ان تساعد الامور وتبعث
فقط باسلحه دفاعيه الى اوكرانيا ولكنها
غيرت من سياساتها خلال الصفقات الصفقات
الاسلحه الاخيره اخر صفقتين او ثلاث صفقات
اصبحت هناك صواريخ تصل مداها ل150 كيلو
متر واصبح هناك
دبابات هجوميه في الافق
وطبعا الالمانيه ايضا ستدخل على الخطوه
تشالنجر البريطانيه ودبابات اخرى تحول الد
العسكريه نوعا ما الى دعم
لامكانيه احداث اوكرانيا فارقا على الارض
بالهجوم المضاد وفي المقابل التصريحات
التي صدرت ايضا
بالامس من مسؤولين امريكيين تدعو اوكرانيا
لاستعداد للقيام بعمليات عسكريه وهجمات ضد
القوات الروسيه في جزيره القرم هذا يعد
تصعيدا من الجانب الامريكي
وروسيا ستاخذ هذا على اعتبار انه تصيد
وربما تدخل مباشر في هذه الحرب من قبل
الولايات المتحده يعني
اذا اعتبرونا
مباشر
الان هي مثل ما وصفتها حرب الوكاله بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وروسيا ولكنها
على ارض اوكرانيه
صحيح صحيح هي الفكره اليوم كيف سترد روسيا
هل لان روسيا دائما تقول ان هذه الحرب من
الممكن ان تتحول الى حرب مباشره بينها
وبين حلف الناتو او بينها وبين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه انا من وجهه نظري اعتقد
ان هناك مساحه
كما يقال بالانجليزيه
[موسيقى]
اعتذر عن مقاطعتك ونستمع الى كلمه الرئيس
الاوكراني
ين
الان في اوكرانيا مصير النظام الدولي
العالمي
يتم
تقريره وانا مع الرئيس بايدن وشركاء
والحلفاء سنواصل بذل كل من نستطيع حتى
ينتصر العالم الديمقراطي في هذه المعركه
التاريخيه
اوكرانيا
تتذكر التركيز والموقف الذي تبناه الرئيس
بايدن والشعب الامريكي واوكرانيا ستواصل
على اتصال مستمر مع رئيس الولايات المتحده
طيله هذه الحرب وهذه هي الزياره الاولى
طيله 15 عاما وهي اهم زياره في تاريخ
العلاقات بين اوكرانيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذه زياره تاتي في اصعب الظروف
التي تمر بها اوكرانيا التي تدافع عن حريه
العالم
وهي تؤكد نتائج التي حققناها
وما يمكن ان نحققه من انجازات معا مع
الولايات المتحده
والعالم واوروبا واليوم
مباحثاتنا كانت مثمره للغايه
وكانت مهمه
وحاسمه وقد اضحك ذلك تقليدا بين بلدين اود
ان اشكر واقدر الرئيس بايدن وفريقه
واشكركم على اشكركم وعلى هذا المستوى الذي
وصلت اليه العلاقات بين البلدين وخلال هذا
الاسبوع سوف نحيي مرورا عام على معركتنا
ضد روسيا
يجب ان نعزز تصميمنا
وزياره في ديسمبر وكذلك زياره السيد
الرئيس الامريكي لاكياف
سوف
ينظر الى اليهما والى هذه الزياره اعلى
انها دليل على عزمنا لتحرير اراضي اراضينا
والاوكرانيا دائما
عبرت عن تقديرها
العلاقات مع الولايات المتحده وكذلك عملت
على ارساء الاساس للتعاون في المجال
الدفاعي وكذلك
اود ان اشكر الرئيس بايدن على كل ما قدمه
من مساعدات عسكريه مثل
الذخائر المعدات الاخرى التي قدمت الى
اوكرانيا
ادركها السيد الرئيس انه سيكون هناك
حزم عسكريه مهمه تقدم الى اوكرانيا وهذا
سيكون اشاره واضحه بان مساعي روسيا لن
تنجح ومعا سوف ندافع
عن مواطنين
ومدننا ضد روسيا وهذا سوف يمنح زخما
لتحقيق النصر وقد اكدنا اليوم ان لدينا
وجهه نظر مشتركه
وكذلك
ننسخ للتصدي للدوله الارهابيه الروسيه
ونعمل على التعزيز
العقوبات ثنائي وفي اطار مجموعه السبعه
ايضا نحن لدينا رؤيه مشتركه بشان محتوى
الكثير من اوجه
العلاقات
الدفاعيه او الامنيه بين بلدينا كما اننا
عازمون على احترام ميثاق الامم المتحده
والدفاع عن النظام العالمي الذي يستند على
القواعد وهذا مهم لكافه الدول التي يهمها
الامن العالمي نحن نريد استعاده العداله
وهذا امر مهم للغايه ايضا لكل اولئك الذين
تضرروا بالارهاب الروسي والحرب الروسيه
ويجب على روسيا ان تعود كافه لضاله تتسببت
بها ونشكر الرئيس الامريكي على دوره ودعمه
لاوكرانيا او لكافه المؤسسات الاوكرانيه
نحن نؤمن بانه لا بديل لاقامه محكمه خاصه
هذا هو موقف اوكرانيا وسوف ندعم هذا
الموقف نود من الولايات المتحده ان تشارك
في تنفيذ اتفاق سلام الذي نقدمه
لتعزيز الاستقرار العالمي وكذلك لتكون
هناك علاقات دوليه يمكن تنبؤ بها خلال هذا
الاسبوع مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واكثر من 60 بلد اخر سوف تقدم هذه الدول
في نيويورك مسوده قرار لدعمي السلامي في
اوكرانيا في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
ونحن نرى ان مشروع
القرار هذا سيكون خطوه مهمه على الطريق
الصحيح
ونحن ايضا
نعمل على
فتحي
او توجيهي نداء تقدير للرئيس بايدن ولقد
اجرينا محادثات
واولين اهتمام خاص لحمايه الديمقراطيه في
اوكرانيا واشكر الرئيس بايدن على مساهمته
لدعم الحريه
والديمقراطيه في العالم
سيتذكر الاوكرانيون ذلك واوكرانيا ممتنه
لكم السيد الرئيس
والمواطنين الامريكيين وكل من يدافعون عن
الحريه كما نفعم النصر لاوكرانيا والنصر
لجنودنا واوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا السيد الرئيس
قبل عام
تحدثنا هاتفيا
كان الوقت
متاخرايه المتحده ومبكرا في الولايات
المتحده دخلت الدبابات الروسيه الى
اوكرانيا قلت لي انك كنت تسمع التفجيرات
في
على مقربه من مكانك واتذكر جيدا عندما
سالتك
ماذا يمكن ان افعله السيد الرئيس كيف يمكن
ان اساعدك
وادرك ما قلته لي وهناك تبس
اجمع قاده العالم واطلب منهم دعم اوكرانيا
قلت انك تتعلم
لا تدري متى يمكن ان نتواصل
مجددا قبل
كان العالم ينتظر سقوط اكياس يبدو وكان
الوقت اطول من عام
ربما
نهايه اوكرانيا ايضا
تعلم بعد عام لا تزال كيف واقفه وكذلك
اوكرانيا لا تزال واقفه مقراتيه قائمه
والولايات المتحده تقف معك والعالم يقف
معك
وكيف قد استولت على جزء من قلب جئت الى
هنا ست مرات كان نائب للرئيس ومره كرئيس
في عام 2009 كان نائب للرئيس عندما جئت
الى هنا لمره الاولى وفي عام 2014 عدت
ثلاث مرات في عقاب بثوره الكرامه ثم عدت
في عام 2015
للوقوف على العمل من اجل بناء ديمقراطيه
قويه
وجئت في عام 2017 قبل ان اغادر منصبي
كنائبي للرئيس كنت اعرف انني ساعود لكنني
لم اعرف متى حتى بعد الانتخابات
قررت انه يجب ان اقوم بزياره اخرى قبل
يتم تنصيب رئيس المقبل الى كيف اذا الرئيس
زيلينس لقد شرفتني هنا في كيف الى جانبك
اليوم
لالتقي مع الجنود
والمس الاستخبارات
ودبلوماسيين وقاده المجتمع الذين ساعدوا
بلدهم وقفوا الى جانبه وقت الحاجه الجميع
وقفوا الى جانب بلادهم الجميع
النساء
والشباب
حاولوا ان يقوموا بشيء ما
يحاولون ان يخرجوا الناس من المباني التي
تعرضت للقصف
في جرائم ضد الانسان امر مذهل العالم
باسره راى ذلك
ونظر الى ذلك
انها اوسع حرب في اوروبا منذ ثلاثه ارباع
القرن ولقمتم تحققون النجاح ضد كل
التوقعات باستثناء توقعاتكم نحن وثقون
بانكم سوف تواصلون تحقيق الانتصار
عندما
تلقيت الاتصال هاتفي بشان الخوف من سقوط
كيف قبل عام كنا نركز على تحديد كيف يمكن
حشد دعم العالم كيف يمكن ان اساعدك في
الوعد الذي طلبته مني وهو جمع قاده العالم
كيف تحقق النجاح كيف يمكن ان نحث العالم
على الاستجابه
من اجل اقتصاد مزدهر وبلد ديموقراطي ودوله
امنه مستقره
عندما
الاتحاد الامريكيون
قرروا الوقوف
الشعب الامريكي يدرك
بان الغزوه والعدوان هو تهديد لنا جميعا
بنين تحالف للدول من الاطلس الى الهادي
النيتو
واليابان في المحيط الهادي اي في العالم
برمته
عدد من الدول عددها تجاوز الخمسين
ساعدت هذه الدول الاوكرانيه للدفاع عن
نفسي وقدمت الدعوه الانساني والاقتصادي
نحن قاده العالم نريد
[موسيقى]
التكلفه على روسيا تؤثر على شريان حياتها
الاقتصادي معا قدمنا حوالي 700 دبابه
والالاف من العربات المدرعه والف من
الانظمه انظمه المدفعي واكثر من مولاي
ذخيره واكثر من خمسين انظمه
الصواريخ المتقدمه ونظام انظمه الدفاع
كلها قدمت للدفاع عن اوكرانيا وطبعا
بالاضافه الى 500 مليون دولار سنعلن عنه
اليوم
وهذا يتغلق بالولايات المتحده فقط واليوم
فقط هذا الاعلان يشمل ايضا ذخائر
وكذلك رادارات الرقابه لحمايه الشعب
الاوكراني من القصف الجوي وفي وقت لاحق
هذا الاسبوع سنععلن عقوبات اضافيه ضد
النخبئ التي تريد ان تتلافى العقوبات
وتساعد روسيا بفضل دعم الحزبين في الكونغ
سنقدم هذا الاسبوع المليارات من الدعم
المالي المباشر من الميزانيه حيث يمكن
للحكومه الاوكراني تستخدم ذلك فورا لتقديم
الخدمات الاساسيه للمواطنين
التكلفه التي على اوكرانيا تحملها باهظه
الى حد كبير
وضحايا اعظم بكثير مما يتوقع نحن
في حاله حداد على اوك الذين قتلوا في هذه
الحرب الوحشيه وغير الظالمه ندرك ان سيكون
هناك ايام وشهور واشهر وسنوات صعبه
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
روسيا كانت ترغب في محو اوكرانيا من على
الخريطه لكن خطه بوتين فشلت وروسيا فقدت
نصف الاراضي التي احتلتها
وشباب الروس يفررون بعشرات الالاف لا
يريدون ان يعودوا الى روسيا
ليس فقط من بين
الجيش ولكن يهربون من روسيا نفسها لانهم
لا يرون اي مستقبل في بلادهم
الاقتصاد الروسي الان في حاله تخلف ومعزول
ويعاني
اعتقد بوتين انه اوكرانيا ضعيفه وان الغرب
منقسم
وكما تعلمون السيد رئيس قلت لك في البدايه
يمكن ان تعول علينا وسنتقف جنبا الى جنب
انه كان يعول على ابقاء انيت متحدا يعود
علينا ان لن نستطيع ان نجلب اخرين الى
النيتو الى جانب اوكرانيا
اعتقد انه يمكن ان يبقى ولكن لا اعتقد انه
يفكر بهذا الامر الان
لا سادري ما يمكن ان يفكر به بل انه
مختل ربما
وقد يثبت انه مخطئ بعد عام مضى
الدليل موجود هنا في هذه القاعه نجد هنا
جنبا الى جنب السيد الرئيس
انا سعيد انني استطعت ان اعيد لك الزياره
الى في بلدك بعدما قدمت الى واشنطن
انه ليس لدينا ايه مخاوف ولا ينبغي لاي ان
كان في العالم ان يكون لديه مخاوف انتهى
الاقتباس السيد رئيس والشعب الاوكراني
تذكرون العالم كل يوم
معنا الشجاعه
كفت القطاعات هنا
كل فئات المجتمع متحدون هذا امر مذهل
هذا يذكرنا بان الحريه لا ثمن لها
ما ان هذه الحريه تستحق ان يضحي الانسان
من اجلها مهما طال الزمن السيد رئيس وهذا
ما سنقدمه لكم من دعم زمن ام قصر
اذا استمعنا الى كلمتي
الرئيسين الامريكي جو بايدن وفولوديمير
زيلينسكي طبعا
تحدث بانه هذه المباحثات كانت مثمره
وبانه
اوكرانيا ستواصل التنسيق مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في هذه الحرب كما ربط
مصير النظام الدولي
بمصير اوكرانيا
نشاهد هذه الصور الخارجيه للرئيسين معا
خلال الجوله في شوارع كياف
طبعا الرئيس بايدن شدد في كلمته على دعم
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه وبانه سيتم فرض المزيد
من العقوبات على الجانب الروسي قريبا
وانه يجب التضحيه من اجل حريه اوكرانيا
طبعا
تحدث بانه روسيا كانت تريد ازاله اوكرانيا
من الخريطه
بما يخص موضوع العقوب موضوع المساعدات
العسكريه وعد بتقديم مليارات الدولارات
لاوكرانيا بالتعاون مع الكونغرس والمزيد
من ذخيره هايمورس وجافلين الى اوكرانيا
طبعا هي اكبر حرب في اوروبا منذ 75 عاما
هكذا وصفها بايدن
ووضع الكياف مكان خاصه في قلبه
طبعا هذه ليست الزياره الاولى
لبايدن الى كييف زارها قبل ان يصبح رئيسا
والان يزورها وهي تعيش حربا
اذا زيلينسكي يتحدث عن انه هناك مقترح
للسلام خاص
به من اذا ينضم الينا من جديد شوماكوف
الدبلوماسي السابق سيد يعني كيف تنظرون
الى هذه الزياره بدايه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
تحيه طيبه من اوكرانيا نعم من المعروف بان
هذا زياره سيد بايدن غير معلنه بصراحه كان
مفاجاه
لشعب الاوكراني واحد من هذا الدعم الكبير
اكيد
سلطه اوكرانيه لشعب اوكرانيا للجيش
اوكرانيا من المعروف
وكما
واحد من المنتظر بل من الممكن سوف يكون
النكاح او تقديم لاوكرانيا
المقاتلات في 16 واحد نحن نطرح سؤال هل
سوف تكون مفاوضات حول انضمام اوكرانيا الى
[موسيقى]
لان هذه صيغه ذهبيه لاوكرانيا انضمام الى
الناطق يعني بصفه عامه هذا الدعم كبير
واكيد الدعم
طيب اليابان الان تتعهد ايضا بتقديم
مساعدات اضافيه لاوكرانيا بقيمه 5.5
مليارات دولار
برايك كيف سيكون رد الفعل الروسي على هذه
الزياره
بصراحه بصفه عامه نحن نتجاهل اي روسي من
المنتظر وروسيا سوف تردوا
صاروخيه على اوكرانيا كيم من الممكن سوف
تكون
زياده من الصراع في منطقه
او خاصه من ارباح ولكن في اقرب وقت نحن
كمان سوف نسمع اضطراب عصبي رو
س في في القنوات
نحن هنا في اوكرانيا نتجاهل باي ايران
روسي من المنتظر بان سوف تكون لا تهديدات
باستخدام الاسلحه نوويه واصلحه كم كيماويه
على اوكرانيا في في حاله الطقس بالمناسبه
لاوكرانيا كمان مهمه جدا الحصول من امريكا
على الضبابات الابرمس لدرس شديد في هذا في
هذا النقاش وفي حضره تصريحات نحن لم نسمع
من بايدن حول ضبابات لاوكرانيا في اقرب
وقت لان اوكرانيا تحتاج هذه
قوه مصالحه روسيه في منطقه وكمان في جنوب
اوكرانيا في محافظه
يعني هكذا زياره لبايدن الى اي مدى يمكن
ان تغلق اي شكل من اشكال او مسارات الحوار
والسلام
القادم من الايام يعني المزيد من
المساعدات العسكريه من الاسلحه المتطوره
باتريوت ااا يعني نستمع بهذه الصور الى
يعني عزف
للنشيد الوطني اعتقد الاوكراني
وصور للجنود
والقتله الاوكران الذين سقطوا بهذه الحرب
الروسيه تفضل
اولا نبغي ادراك باننا نحن نحارب مع جيش
رقم اثنين في العالم اذا تذاكر لبنان مين
بدايه حرف اوكرانيا طلبت من غرب وخاصه من
امريكا اغلاق الجو
وطلبت اسلحه متطوره ومنها الدبابات ومنها
مدرعات ومنها المخاطلات
سوف تحصل الى هذه الدبابات تقريبا بعد سنه
وشهرين من هجوم روسيا على اوكرانيا كما
نحن نشهد بان بوتين وهو يطلب المفاوضات
ولكن هو لا يطلب السلام بهذا السابق من
المنتظر بانه حرب هي سوف تكون
طويله وللاسف الشديد الضمويه للغايه نحن
نشهد عند الروس لا توجد اي مبادئ اخلاقيه
عند مروسيا طقس في مدن اوكرانيا وبنيه
تحقيق اساسيه وبنيه تحتيه هنا
في اوكرانيا اوكرانيا بالدم والدموع
اطفالي ونساء اوكرانيا وبهذا السابق
اوكرانيا في حاجه ماسه الى مساعده من اغرب
وخاصه بالضبابات وخاصه مقاتلات
ولكن نحن شاكرين جدا في خاصه لصيد على
كبيره امريكا تقدم لاوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا لك من اكياف فولو
الدبلوماسي السابق